[Music]
good afternoon
and welcome to this session of how the
light gets in i'm aisha hazarica
i'm a political commentator and
broadcaster and former political
advisor to the uk labour party and i'm
delighted
to be joined by paul krugman we all know
that he's one of the world's leading
economists winner of the nobel
prize and also one of america's most
important political
commentators and columnists with his new
york times
uh column which i'm sure you all read
fastidiously
and and he's also the author of many
books including
how to argue with zombies so i'm
delighted to be here with paul
paul welcome um you have to start
with um there's only one story in town
across the whole world and of course
that is the covert
crisis and we have a huge public health
crisis
which is colliding with a huge economic
crisis that's coming down the
track we know that unemployment is huge
in america it's huge in countries
all over the place certainly here in the
united kingdom there's been attempts at
a stimulus
following stuff trying to prop wages up
but what do you think
governments should be doing now and what
should they be doing going forward to
sort of
try and shape and man manage this huge
the mother of all recessions that's
coming down the track
okay the way to think about it or the
way i've been arguing is that we should
think about this as
this is not a normal recession um and
the response shouldn't be
stimulus it's actually kind of the wrong
word to use for what we should be doing
we are shutting down economies uh
because we should
because the way to cope with the
pandemic
is that you need to as as we say not
just flatten the curve but crush it you
need to bring down
the the infected share of the population
to a level where you can do
uh testing tracing isolating um and
and only then or when a vaccine finally
comes along can
can you really start to reopen safely um
so it's it's i've been saying that it's
like putting the economy in an induced
coma
medically induced coma where you such
things down for the sake of safety
now the problem is that that that
that's an inconvenience for people who
are
still earning you know still have have
adequate incomes uh but with but that's
certainly tolerable but it's it's a much
bigger deal for people who
lose their jobs or for businesses that
that lose in
their business um and so the the role of
economic policy is to make that shutdown
that necessary shutdown that is there to
save lives
um tolerable so it's really more
disaster relief
than it is uh stimulus and um
and there are ways to do it and in fact
despite
everything almost despite ourselves i
think most of the advanced world
is doing a significant amount not enough
but it's
you know we the uh that we've made it
the the amount of misery out there is
not nearly as much as
the headline unemployment figures might
have
might suggest and in terms of
going forward and you know lots of
governments are now
really um trying to make that balance
and perhaps it is not a false choice but
they are kind of setting up a sort of
you know
health versus wealth um which is which
is probably a false choice
what's your advice to them going
forward you know how should they be
trying to manage
easing the lockdown and trying to kind
of get the economy going a wee bit how
do they manage that in a way
which is safe to people's health but
also gets the economy going in the right
way
well you want to be extremely extremely
cautious i mean the
the thing about pandemics i mean is that
the
that um if you are even
just slightly uh if each
infected person infects just slightly
more than one other
person then you have exponential growth
and so you don't want that to happen a
second time that's that's economically
destructive on top of killing a lot of
people so you want to be really really
cautious you want to err on the side of
doing less you want to
think it through and you want to make
sure you really don't want to be open
until you've got
the uh the number of infected people
down
a long ways and you've got a whole
testing
and and tracing isolating infrastructure
in place
now that's not what's happening what's
happening is that we're
instead seeing a kind of uh
you know impatience and uh i think so so
part of the whole problem is that
i mean i i'm obviously following my own
country best
uh we've had a half
effective uh response enhanced
unemployment benefits
some but although that's programs are
met but some incentives for firms to
keep
workers on payroll um and which has you
know
it's it's uh inadequate but in fact
most of the unemployed are in fact are
receiving benefits which are making up
most of the lost income
so we're we've done a lot but the
one side of our political political
spectrum hates that
and they are desperate to you know stop
all of this
uh aid to people in in difficulty and
reopen the economy instead
and i'm i've i'm very nervous i think
we're
we were just you know you the data
aren't conclusive yet but it's starting
to look as if we're
we're losing we're we're starting to see
an uptick in hospitalizations and
uh so i i have a very uh
very a lot of foreboding about where
we're going right now
well i think these divisions are very
interesting because they are
you know there's a there's a sense i
think in in certainly in my country and
i definitely feel in your country with
the politics
there's the sort of um doves versus the
hawks
in terms of the ideological differences
and
and so this kind of false choice between
health and
and wealth which is is is is just it's
not the way it should be
but in terms of and i really like your
um
analogy with aid and disaster relief
because this is
exactly what what this is but in order
to to keep
doing that obviously that involves
governments
being prepared to spend the money borrow
money
big borrowing means big debt which is
quite frightening to a lot of people
because they have been
educated to believe that debt is a bad
thing they're
taught in their own lives debt is bad
and they're taught
by the establishment in politics and
economics
that governmental debt is bad as well so
how do you argue the case for
more spending when people are very
nervous about the
economic future yeah i mean the thing to
say
first off is that view of debt
the the analogy between um
an individual family's debt and the debt
of
a government is a very poor one um the
the uh
or the the tendency is to think oh
if we have a lot of government debt that
means that we have
borrowed at the expense of our future
but in fact
um you know the the debt isn't is for
the most part
leaving out international borrowing but
that has not actually a big factor in
all of this
um who's who is the debt owed to
um and the debt is owed to domestic
residents it's basically we
i i like to say that debt is money we
owe to ourselves which drives people
crazy but is in fact
the obvious truth the we have a big
expansion right now in
in governmental debt both sides of the
atlantic and
overwhelmingly that's matched by an
increase in assets held by people
so what's really happening is one way to
think about what's happening right now
is that um the government is channeling
money from people whose
livelihood is intact uh but actually
have money that they can't spend because
there are a lot of things you can't go
to a restaurant so on um it's channeling
money from those people to people whose
livelihoods have been
temporarily suspended um and it
that's that's what we need to do that's
the social insurance aspect
but uh we're not paying for that with an
immediate rise in taxes
uh we are instead paying for it by by
issuing ious
which is a perfectly reasonable um and
uh perfectly responsible thing to do
it would only be a an issue if you
thought that there was
a that we were imminently in danger of
hitting the limits of what
governments can credibly promise to
repay
and we're nowhere close to that none of
us are i mean
i actually like to look at the uk um the
history of the uk
in the for much of the 20th century the
uk had huge debts it came out of world
war one with a big debt
that it really didn't bring down it came
out of world war ii with debt that was
250 percent of gdp so way you know
more than double current levels um never
never a problem
um advanced countries have an enormous
ability to
to take on debts in times of emergency
which is where we are right now
although i think what what is really
missing
is a kind of public explainer
how this debt works because in the
united kingdom for example
the that that argument really wasn't
made
very effectively you know we were told
in subsequent elections after the global
financial crisis when our government
like many other governments had to
borrow a lot to stop our you know banks
and things going off a cliff edge
we were told oh no this borrowing is is
bad and
um you know debt is bad and it's
important to
get the deficit down and we have to pay
off all this debt now and that's why
we needed fiscal restraint and austerity
and really extreme
cuts to public spending and i think a
lot of people
bought that line you know because they
voted in
governments who were promulgating that
line and yet austerity has not worked
austerity has not worked for for the
united kingdom
probably not work for america how do we
better make that argument
well okay part of the problem to
continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas